our defense and security analyst
Professor Michael Clark and Professor
Clark we're just listening um to Dominic
there and talk to me about the
significance that that you feel is uh
attached to the introduction of Iranian
drones even though Russia says they're
not from Iran yeah no they're definitely
Iranian drones so Jane the Iranians can
deny it all they like they are Shahid
136 drones absolutely certain and the
American intelligence British
intelligence is totally certain the
point about them is they're not very
sophisticated but they're cheap enough
you can have a lot of them so they
traveled about 100 miles an hour they
have quite a small Warhead they can only
attack fixed targets they work on normal
GPS and they've attacked targets all
over Ukraine in zatimir and nepro they
had quite significant outages of Power
and Water and in calcium civilian
casualties in Kiev the point about these
things they cost about twenty thousand
dollars each the next biggest missile
the ss21 costs about three hundred
thousand dollars each so you can have
any number and the the Russians have got
hundreds of these things from Iran and
they launched them in back batteries are
five at a time so they launched 60 or 80
at a single Target the ukrainians say
that they've interdicted about 80
percent of them they possibly have
they've certainly done very well but
even at 80 some of them get through and
although they don't carry a particularly
big war ahead about a fifth the size of
a warhead of a ballistic missile if it
hits your apartment Block it's going to
kill somebody and it can put out
critical National infrastructure nodes
like power and water and so on so they
are having an effect it's not a
strategic effect it's an effect on the
population yeah um let's talk about
what's happening in the southwest of the
country shall we yeah well what's
happening here is that we don't know
what's happening that's really important
okay the um ukrainians have conducted a
complete news blackout on what's
happening in the curse and oblast
because the Russians are holding a line
between snohrifica and milove and that
line they've been holding on to for over
a week now as the Ukraine's move South
and they're also holding in cursing the
Ukraine's are trying to get around the
round of southwest of Kirsten and have
been trying that for a little while when
the ukrainians have a news blackout it
means something's going on and they've
always done this before when there's a
big offensive push on so I'm guessing
that in the next 48 72 hours they might
tell us what's happening but now for for
sure something big is happening might
fail may not work but in the past it has
worked and stand by for some more
interesting information I'm guessing on
this front line between milova and snow
Rifka okay well we watch and wait there
um a prison swap has taken place 108
women
um freed as part of that what can we
read into it how does that play into
this world yeah I mean there are
prisoner exchanges a while ago there
were 200 odd men were exchanged now 100
odd women all from the as of style uh
steel works that you know that big sort
of uh
um resistance in uh in Mario poll and
what's interesting about this I mean
these exchanges are organized by the Red
Cross who work very secretly very
importantly but look these women are all
coming out some of them are in combats
they might have been given those combats
but look they're walking in fine they're
coming out they're almost marching
they're coming out in good order they're
making a point where we're the women
from avastal steel works you know there
were civilians got mixed in with the
troops towards the end it was all pretty
awful but here they are they're holding
their heads up they're coming out with
pride and that's making a point to the
Russians and to the rest of the world I
always say that they'll be making
Hollywood films about what happened in
Mario Paul in years to come these women
will probably feature in it yeah I would
imagine so um but a little bit of good
news to end there on um Professor
Michael Clarke thank you for speaking